Hi everyone.
Welcome to how Foundry integrates with open source frameworks and
technology.
My name is Fakundo, Principal Product Manager at Microsoft, and
today I'm joined by Nakumar, Senior Software Engineer also at
Microsoft, who's going to be driving the keyboard.
So today question is super simple.
If you build an agent using an open source technology,
how you package and deploy that to production without having
to rewrite it.
And for that, we brought you hopefully an interesting setup.
So I'm pretty sure all of you are familiar with
Opencloth, these general purpose agents that can browse the web,
they can search for your emails, they can do stuff
for you and whatnot.
So today we're going to build our own Opencloth Live
using open source frameworks and technologies and then deploy it
to Microsoft Foundry to take you to production.
So let's get started.
Let's start from the bottom.
Nakumar, if I want to build an agent with no
magic platform, no foundry, what is the minimum of code
that I need to get it done?
At the core, we need a model and an agent
loop.
An agent loop is what keeps the agent moving.
It asks the model for the next step, runs tools
when needed, and uses each result to decide what happens
next.
This file is intentionally small.
The model comes from Lang chains in a chat model
and the loop is built with create deep agent.
The important point is that this is simple Lang chain
Lang graph style code.
Most of the foundry models expose open AI compatible APIs,
so Lang chain can talk to a foundry model using
the same protocol it understands.
Changing the model target is configuration, not a rewrite.
So you are saying that in this case LAN chain
owns the Asian loop via that create deep Asian function
and then Foundry provides the models via the open AI
compatible protocol, right?
Right.
I'll run the small local agent first and if I
see this and say hello, we can see that the
agent replied back.
OK, so this is useful, but of course like it
cannot do anything else out of what the model already
knows, right?
So one of the reasons agents like Openflow are so
popular is because they can't get things done, right?
So what's the open source pattern that we should use
to get this agent to do stuff for us?
The open source pattern is MCP Model Context Protocol is
an open protocol that lets an agent discover tools and
call them.
For this demo, the MCP server is Work IQ Mail
which gives the agent access to Microsoft 365 mail capabilities
through tool interface.
The agent does not need to know every Http://endpoint that
Microsoft 365 exposes.
It connects to the Work IQ MCP server, asks for
tools and then receives the tool schemas like search messages,
get message details, draft replies and so on to show
you how the code looks like.
So this is a different agent, but now with the
MCP.
Yeah, OK.
And then we see that the URL is being passed
from here and we go back to the same agent
loop and we are just adding them as tools.
So you are saying that I can take any land
graph agent that I already have pointing to these MCP
server using the open source protocol and get access to
work IQ mail capabilities, calendar capabilities, teams and whatnot, right?
Yes, let me show you how to run this.
So here's my agent with the MCP enabled and I'm
going to ask her to check my e-mail.
While the spinner is moving, watch the tool boundary.
The agent discovered that mail tools at runtime and chose
the right one.
We are also keeping the output kind of sort of
clean.
Now the same local agent can call Microsoft 365 through
MCP.
The tool boundary is inspectable and the agent is just
normal Python code.
Awesome yes we can.
Well we can see it came back like you find
5 emails like through the work IQ MCP server.
So this is useful that the agent has hands.
But like this, this is not nothing interesting in the
sense of it doesn't save me time, right?
Knowing which are the emails that I haven't read is
not that special.
Maybe what I want is this agent to triage my
inbox, which require like knowing a bit more about how
to use each and every tool.
What's the open source pattern that we can use up
here to teach our agent how to use this?
This is where skills come in.
Tools are like verbs, search messages.
A skill is a playbook like triaging Inbox, which can
pull some fields, classify the emails into categories, assign part,
you know, priority, and draft some replies when asked.
I'm going to show you how to run the skills
agent.
So this one's my agent with skills, and I'm going
to ask it to triage my inbox.
And while this agent is running, we can also take
a look at Oh yeah.
We can say that it pick up the the triage
skill, but like we can see it started using some
some tools, but how the agent actually came across with
this skill that you're mentioning or how he discovered?
It.
So the agent uses this skill document.
This skill is just a markdown document with a small
formatting block.
There is no special service or proprietary schema.
The agent reads it when the prompt is relevant.
Now, if we look at the skills, you can see
that we mount the skills into a virtual skills path.
The agent can list it and look at it when
it needs guidance.
Now let's go back to the term or terminal and
see what's going on.
We can see that the agent still running but something
interesting to see now we see multiple tools being called
different from what we saw before.
The only one tool was go out and we can
even see like tools like get message which it looks
to be searching for the actual content of the of
the e-mail which makes sense, right?
Like you cannot triage an e-mail without knowing a bit
more about what is inside of it or what was
the specific request.
We can see it came back and now we got
a triage summary.
Which are the important things that I need to look
out?
Which is the category, which is the recommended action, and
which are the reasons for having on that action, right?
So this is way different because it's the same model,
it's the same tools, but the behavior is completely different,
right?
And this is coming from the power of this reusable
skill.
Yep, that's the big point.
Skills are a lightweight way to make agent behavior repeatable
without turning every instruction into a massive system prompt.
That's all.
Another thing that usually you can see in in agents
like Open Clue is the ability to browse the web
right, which opens you a doors for doing a lot
of other things.
What's our the the open source story if I want
to bring that capabilities to an agent using open source
technologies?
We can use something called Playwright.
Playwright is an open source framework which exposes the CLI
utility and we can also add the skill to kind
of teach the agent what to do using that playwright
CLI.
Now if we look at this agent dot PY here,
I've added my playwright tool to my get tools method
and send all the tools with it.
Now here's an agent which has that playwright tool setup
and I'm going to ask it to open Amazon and
tell me the price of the first Microsoft branded coffee
cup.
OK.
Yeah, we can see that now we pick up a
different skill.
The web browser is using that Playwright CLI tool that
you mentioned, plus the MCP server that we have today.
But actually, considering that like before we work IQ, we
connect our agent to an MCP server, now we're giving
the agent access to a CLI tool on the command
line.
Why did we took this different approach?
What is different here?
Yeah, we could have used the MCP server, but browser
work usually creates a large tool surface.
Here the command line is a simpler utility.
The Python tool has 1 ARC string and an optional
browser session.
Snapshots and command details only enter the context window when
the agent asks for them.
Nice, So what you're saying is that this is not
only easier for the model to use to use the
command line to navigate and open a browser, but it's
also more token efficient, right?
Because like the agent doesn't need to connect to an
MCP server.
Retrieve those big Jason files.
Sorry, instructions with the with the method description, the arguments
that need to be used, feedback to the model in
each other return and then generate generate a response.
So he came back, he said I couldn't find a
Microsoft branded cup, but the first non Microsoft bag that
he found is 1619.
We don't know what happened but I've learned to inspect
the trace to know why it didn't found it.
So now a fair question from the audience because everything
that you have done so far is running on the
terminal.
But if our production users probably don't want to be
SSH in like your laptop, right?
So what's our story to take this to production?
How can Foundry help us in this journey?
Exactly as you said, Foundry hosts the same land graph
agent as a hosted agent and exposes it through an
open AI compatible responses API.
This file is the adapter layer.
Notice that we call the same build agent that we
used earlier and there are two important things, the responses
host server.
It exposes the land graph agent as a responsible responses
compatible endpoint and then we initialize the Foundry server host
before we build the graph so the open telemetry land
chain instrumentation can attach before the graph is constructed.
Nice.
So if I'm reading this correctly, so we are wrapping
our agent in the responses API protocol.
So this technically speaking can run locally in my machine
but also on the cloud right?
So it's the same code but like I'm running both
places.
Correct.
For the sake of this demo, I had the agent
deployed and then I'm going to send my triage prompt
here.
Triage my inbox maybe?
Zoom in a bit so it's not that small.
There we go.
OK, so, so we see that the agent is is
running, but probably, I mean as it happened just with
the with the browser that we didn't found the the
answer that we were expecting.
How can I know exactly what the agent did were
the steps that it performed and be let's say more
insightful about how or where or what are the actions
that the agent is actually taking?
What can we do for that?
Foundry integrates with Application Insights and Open Telemetry.
The demo uses the Microsoft Open Telemetry distro and Open
Telemetry Gen.
AI semantic conventions.
So we can expect inspect the line graph, span model
calls, latencies, captured input and output.
So I can head out to the Traces tab and
in the Traces tab, once we will be able to
see all the requests that we've been sending to it.
And then we'll also see some more details around how
long the request took.
And the interesting thing about like you mentioned opens open
telemetry with semantic conventions.
The interesting thing about that is it's an open source
standard adopted widely adopted by the industry.
So I can use Foundry as we are using right
now, but I can use any other tool, Grafana or
any interesting Divaga tool that I want to use because
the data is open so I can only focus on
all its content, right?
Yes.
So here you can see the invoke agent span and
the chat span from one of the Foundry traces view.
You can also do a trace replay and so on.
We can also get to see a historical trace which
I had opened up which can showcase the user input,
the user output, all the tool actions that it took.
The interesting one is here it try to execute a
tool to read the skill which we had asked it
to read, to know how to, you know, triage my
e-mail.
Yeah, this is all because like when you are moving
things to production like this is when you get surprised
about like where the time that your agent is taking
is being spent and which is all your, your budget
being spent, right.
Like here we can see the amount of tokens that
each of the sections is taking.
So you can know exactly where your money is, is
going, which are the sections that require most of the
maybe improvement or or or adaptation for, for your use
case, Right.
OK.
So last question, I know that 2026 is all of
our like Asians calling other agents, composing and whatnot.
So what's the open source, let's say, approach here?
Can this agent that we just deployed be consumed by
other agent?
How that will work?
Yes, one of the most interesting things of hosting the
agent in Microsoft Foundry is that I get an A
to a endpoint that another A to a compatible client
can use to discover the agent card and send messages
to the hosted agent.
Let's see how this works with copilot CLI.
I have copilot CLI and asked it to talk to
the agent and I can ask it to triage my
inbox and while this is working we can see how
of the setup is being done.
Yeah, let's take a look about how how this copilot
session is is finding our agent and how is invoking
it.
Yeah.
So Copilot, in the Copilot agent, we expose a tiny
A to a directory as an MCP server.
And we added two tools, the search agent and the
call agent A to a tool.
This is the information that Copilot uses to search for
an agent in the directory and invoke the agent via
the A to A.
Now let's go back to the terminal to see what
Copilot is doing.
So let's pause here for a minute because like there
is a lot of composition happening here.
So we are in compiler studio, sorry in compiler CLI,
a completely different runtime.
This this compiler session.
It searched for an agent using our MCP server.
It looks through the directory with all the available agents
that are available there.
It found one.
If you see the line like a search agent, it
found one agent that can actually perform the tasks that
the user asked for.
It invoked the agent using the HOA protocol which is
actually hosted in Microsoft Foundry which under the hood is
the one that we just built, is using Landgraf as
the agent loop model for for Foundry is calling work
IQ which is hosted in an MCP server.
Is using that to get access to my inbox 3,
get all the emails, get all the content, use the
skill to triage all the content of that e-mail, reply
back and get that answer to compiler CLI that then
used to answer this question.
So the beauty of this is like none of these
components knew about each other, right?
Like so they will be in isolation, which is composing
all of them.
So that's the that's the story, that's the open source
story that we wanted to tell in this demo, how
you compose each of these these modules using open source
standards.
And then you can compose a bigger solution by using
those open interfaces.
So you are free to change them at any at
any time.
So that's the story we want to tell with open
source.
That's the story we want you to take away from
this session.
So I think it's a wrap.
Thank you everyone for for the time want to stick
around here for for questions if you have it.
But like you can check out the repo we have
there all the content that we were showing here, all
the different stages of the agent as we were moving
forward.
So you can play with that and and see see
the result.
Thank you.